some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
forty and their chicken deep-fried I
think we all know who were talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
I once met a last Sofia she was drunk on
barley wine I'd been to see for months a
three I knew I could make her mine and
the last was passed consent so it was
off with her we went
and rested her hands because that's what
gentlemen do
[Music]
[Music]
disrespectfully on
there once was a gala from Leeds who I
heard was good on her knees
so I docked my ship for an overnight
trip to take care of all my needs to his
mind tales to tell mi best wig on the
swell register down in perform
cunnilingus for an hour or so
[Applause]
[Music]
I once had a woman so fair whose womb
contained my hair with a son by my side
the Seas we dried the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so I did
support when she chose to a buddy and
therefore her choice we don't say we
don't say or language
with the golden eye and the doctor said
she would die so she emptied her purse
to lift the curse and pray to stay alive
she awoke the very next day hand in her
grave she lay but the scariest part of
the story from the start is I bet you
assumed the doctor was a man there was a
slot with tedster yeah
[Music]
cuz it's Yoho but we don't say Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's read weapons
[Music]
dreamin of the girl with the red hair
and freckles and her eyes like the skies
of blue touch music I grew up in Texas
you know so alright keep her safe from
the home is in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking the reefer and
acting like clowns keep that pretty high
dress from getting dirty and brown cuz
that's the American Way oh pretty racist
song racist against who of black people
black people men but I'm black well
keeping the redheaded girl away from the
homies on the wrong side of town homies
come on brother this is all kinds of
homies you know white homies Asian
homies homies are black no I think
you're making them black man I mean that
I think that's your stuff you hear the
twang and then you assume that it's
racist but that's that's just what
country music is like look you're gonna
like this you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep-fried a thing
we all know we're talking about the only
dark I like is when I turn off the
lights the only hood I love this party
and white and trust you if I can't see
your face at night hey stop that that's
racist what's what what is racist about
it the only hood I love is pointy and
white yeah man let's talk about the Klan
man the Ku Klux Klan are you outside of
your mind that's traditional country
music imagery man like a pickup truck or
sleeping under the stars or your dog got
killed your wife left you same thing I
would have been fine with any of those
things what is the difference between
those things and what is in the song
they're not racial hey you know what I
just say something man I'm just gonna be
frank you're getting a little like Al
Sharpton like Farrakhan on me right now
oh my god are you serious hey can you
you know can't do one more let me just
do one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song it's not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such okay it seems like you're about to
sing the most racist song so far
[Applause]
come on man hey Shh over here trying to
sing about a tire swing
light up an entire genre music the banjo
strumming and the drums are a banging
let's get the boys together and have
ourselves a hanging oh damn now I see it
now I see it one at a time
hot put men like you behind bars every
day one at a you may take my years but
cannot lock my show
oh the years ahead through the zoo Edo
Chinese in the shadows on the shape
[Music]
[Music]
now this is just the Joker taking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the city on fire what's with all
the smoke oh now we're all ears
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cuz what y'all been through yeah
yeah check it out it was Friday night
chillin on my front lawn me and my crew
I had my bathrobe on everybody hi
just watch x-men got plenty chicken
heads ready for sex man roll up
[Music]
we're back to my palace fast now I'm the
dude walking round with a phallus casts
like Wolverine I'm trying to be alone up
but they thinkin got an adamantium
Boulder what can I say they still up on
my totem pole [ __ ] did your tongue ring
away from the scrotum hole don't know
why they love it but it keeps the lady's
moistening gave half the honey's in the
hood lead poisoning
[Music]
they shot
[Music]
Godsey man damn
the Hertz j-mo video over man videos
over I'm serious man
[Music]